let's go next to Jane from Hollywood
Jane from Hollywood welcome to the
program what is on your mind today
Jane from Hollywood I've invited you to
join us you do have to accept that
invitation and then we'll be able to
chat about whatever is on your mind
and last opportunity for Jane from
Hollywood please
all right a failed attempt with Jane
from Hollywood that is that is sad why
don't we try Ronald from Illinois Ronald
from Illinois welcome to the program
Ron please save us from the tech
troubles that are plaguing everyone
yes I can
a good
good
um first first of all I want to say did
you enjoy your vacation I did enjoy it
thank you
all right that's good but um this news
with Clarence Thomas and Clarence Thomas
and all the Republicans that's being you
know like Ollie business put out do you
think that's Trump them doing it
sorry you're saying do I think it's
Trump putting out these negative stories
about Clarence Thomas
Clarence Thomas all the other
Republicans I mean just because he's
failing do you think that he's
intentionally bringing them down with
him I don't think so I mean that's an
interesting question which is Trump gets
arrested and indicted does he try to
take attention away from himself by
publishing all of this uh you know very
sketchy Financial activity by Clarence
Thomas I don't I I have no reason to
believe that's what's going on let me
put it that way
all right David that was my
first month all right there is a Ronald
from Illinois great to hear from you